la Réunion
je suis un collègue je vais je vais donc
ouvrir
cette audition suivant les
formes j'allais dire à coutumer après
les auditions du directeur général de
l'énergie et du climat puis du
secrétaire général des affaires
européennes ont poursuit aujourd'hui les
travaux de notre mission d'information
par une table ronde sur le thème des
technologies et de la recherche dans le
domaine des biocarburants des carburants
de synthèse durable et de l'hydrogène
vert
quatre organismes y participent le
commissariat l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives le Centre national
de la recherche scientifique l'Agence
nationale de la recherche et l'Institut
français du pétrole énergie nouvelle
cette réunion est captée
je le précise pour tout le monde et les
diffuser en direct sur le site
interne du Sénat sur lequel on pourra
par la suite
consulter la vidéo à la demande et ainsi
que sur Twitter
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir cet
après-midi monsieur Thibault Cantat
directeur de recherche et chef du
programme économie circulaire du carbone
au commissariat de l'énergie atomique et
aux énergies alternatives Monsieur
Philippe Hérault
responsable du programme biomasse vers
carburant à l'IFP énergie nouvelle
monsieur Alexandre Legris directeur
adjoint scientifique de l'Institut de
chimie du Centre national de la
recherche scientifique qui est
accompagnée par Monsieur Thomas Borel
responsable des affaires publiques et en
visio j'espère que tout le monde nous
entend bien du côté de la visio Monsieur
Pascal bain responsable du département
Sciences Physiques
ingénieur ingénieur et chimie énergie à
l'Agence nationale de la recherche qui
est accompagnée de madame Cécile choux
chargé de mission relation
institutionnelle à la direction générale
de l'Agence nationale de la recherche
mesdames alors madame mes messieurs
notre mission d'information comprend 23
mai membre ils sont
issus de des différentes commissions du
Sénat et représentent l'ensemble des
groupes politiques du Sénat
avec mes collègues nous sommes
convaincus de l'enjeu que représente le
développement des filières de
biocarburant de carburantes synthèse
durable et hydrogène vert tant pour la
capacité de la France et de l'Union
européenne à atteint l'objectif de
neutralité à l'horizon 2050 que pour
notre souveraineté et la compétitivité
compétitivité de notre économie les
organismes que vous représentez sont des
acteurs majeurs de la recherche
scientifique et technologique sur les
énergies bocarbone plus particulièrement
dans le domaine de la décarbonation des
transports qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui soit en conduisant
directement des recherches soit en les
finalisant notamment par le biais
d'appels à projets je vous propose que
chacun d'entre nous d'entre vous puisse
nous présenter dans le cadre d'un propos
liminaire on va dire d'une dizaine de
minutes si vous devez passer on vous en
voudra pas
le champ d'action et les programmes
conduits par sa structure dans le
domaine de la recherche sur les
biocarburants les carburants
synthétiques durables et hydrogène vert
vous
pourriez ainsi nous préciser votre
vision du degré de maturité
technologique des solutions
envisageables de leur capacité à être
portées par l'industrie française et
européenne ainsi que de leur
contribution potentielle à la
décarbonation du secteur des transports
notre rapporteur mon collègue Vincent
capo canelas vous a adressé un
questionnaire qui peut vous servir de
guide mais vous n'êtes pas obligé de le
suivre si vous voulez nous présenter les
choses autrement
je passerai à la suite
la parole à notre rapporteur puis à
l'ensemble des de mes collègues afin
qu'ils puissent vous relancer vous poser
un certain nombre de questions vous
pourrez nous transmettre
ultérieurement des réponses écrites aux
questions qui vous ont été adressées par
notre rapporteur je propose et que
Monsieur Thibault Quentin directeur de
recherche chef du projet
Économie circulaire du carbone au
commissariat de l'énergie atomique et
énergie alternative comment cet échange
et je vous cède la parole
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup mesdames et messieurs les
membres de la commission pour pour cette
invitation à participer à cette table
ronde donc entre polymère quelques mots
tout d'abord sur le CEA pour vous
rappeler que c'est un organisme de
recherche dont le but est déclarer des
éclairer pardon la décision publique et
donner les moyens que ce soit
scientifiques et technologiques aux
différentes forces vives que ce soit le
tissu industriel les entreprises les
collectivités notamment pour mieux
maîtriser les mutations sociétales
majeures auxquelles on fait face que ce
soit la transition énergétique numérique
la santé du futur la défense et la
sécurité de globale et donc on a
l'organisme au cœur des territoires avec
9 centres qui sont répartis sur tout
l'Hexagone la plupart équipés de très
grandes infrastructures de recherche
avec une démarche de partenariat que ce
soit des partenariats académiques
industriels en France en Europe et à
l'étranger
en ce qui concerne l'énergie le CEA
promeut une vision intégrée de l'énergie
c'est à dire une vision qui va s'appuyer
sur la complémentarité de toutes les
sources d'énergie de la carbone qu'elles
soient des nouvelles technologies de
l'énergie et de l'énergie nucléaire
ainsi on va développer on a on a
l'ambition d'être un acteur de premier
plan et de développer les technologies
autour du photovoltaïque des systèmes de
stockage énergétique notamment à base de
batterie mais aussi avec le vecteur
hydrogène l'amélioration de l'efficacité
énergétique et évidemment l'insertion
des énergies renouvelables dans les
réseaux énergétiques
le CEA également investi dans des
recherches de plus long terme qui vont
concerner l'économie circulaire que ce
soit l'économie circulaire des matières
mais aussi du carbone dont on va parler
aujourd'hui notamment pour faire émerger
des technologies qui seront compatibles
avec l'objectif de neutralité carbone à
donc sur ces trois filières que sont
l'hydrogène vert les biocarburants et
les carburants de synthèse qu'on
appellera aussi icarburant le CEA a une
position qui va différer
en effet sur le côté biocarburant et
carburant de synthèse la position du CA
est de développer prioritairement des
briques technologiques génériques au
profit de la communauté académique ou
industrielle avec une vision que la
solution énergétique neutre en carbone
en 2050 va nous conduire à avoir à
développer des solutions qui soient
indépendantes de l'origine du carbone
que ce soit du CO2 ou du carbone
biogénique
la situation par contre sur l'hydrogène
est assez différente puisque ce vecteur
apparaît comme une solution dans la
maturité technologique permet déjà de
débuter un déploiement industriel massif
même si des progrès évidemment
technologiques sont encore nécessaires
et donc on va voir que sur cet axe de
l'hydrogène le CEA aborde la recherche
et le développement sur toute la chaîne
de valeur en privilégiant tout d'abord
les composants et les systèmes pour la
production d'hydrogène par électrolyse à
haute température le stockage de
l'hydrogène dans des réservoirs haute
pression ou plus récemment sous forme
liquide que ce soit à travers la
fixation de l'hydrogène de façon
réversible sur des molécules liquides ou
bien sur du stockage cryogénique et
enfin la conversion de l'hydrogène avec
des pieds la combustible que ce soit
depuis la combustible de type PEM à
basse température ou de type haute
température
donc ces activités à s'inscrivent
parfaitement dans le cadre de la
Stratégie nationale hydrogène qui est
portée par l'État et dans ce domaine le
CEA développé des partenariats
industriels privilégiés entre autres
avec la société genevia pour tout ce qui
concerne l'électrolyse haute température
et les sociétés Symbio et inaucelles
pour tout ce qui est pile à combustible
de type peine
donc l'ensemble de ces efforts de R&D
finalement vise à contribuer à répondre
aux enjeux de la neutralité carbone pour
2050 en lien avec la stratégie nationale
bas carbone et la PPE et à ce titre il
convient de rappeler que le mix
énergétique français est basé à 60 % sur
l'utilisation de ressources carbonées
essentiellement fossiles car issus du
gaz naturel et du carbone du cas
naturelle pardon et du pétrole ce qui
veut dire que remplacer cette part
carbonée par des alternatives qui
n'émettent pas de gaz à effet de serre
vont représenter un enjeu de premier
plan notamment pour assurer la stabilité
et la souveraineté de notre système
énergétique dans sa globalité
donc il convient donc de promouvoir à la
fois une plus grande sobriété une plus
grande efficacité énergétique il
convient de le rappeler ici mais aussi
d'augmenter notre capacité de production
en électricité bas carbone de manière à
électrifier tous les procédés qui
peuvent l'être et qui actuellement
mettent en œuvre des ressources fossiles
comme l'électricité ne peut pas être
stockée il est nécessaire également de
développer les technologies et des
vecteurs énergétiques qui vont être
capables de répondre à l'ensemble des
services qui sont actuellement couverts
par les ressources fossiles et je parle
là de procéder de secteur d'activité qui
sont extrêmement difficiles à décarboner
en premier lieu les transports mais ça
peut être aussi la production de biens
de consommation la production de chaleur
à très haute température etc
dans ce sens la production d'hydrogène
vert de biocarburant de carburant de
synthèse à partir de ressources
renouvelables telles que l'eau
l'électricité bas carbone et le CO2 ou
la biomasse comme source de carbone
biogénique ça représente une possibilité
pour atteindre une neutralité carbone
dans tous les secteurs d'activité qui
sont les plus difficiles à des carbone
en ce sens les visions du CEA elle est
systémiques et à l'articule les trois
filières en ce sens qu'on va développer
des axes de recherche et développement
autour des biocarburants essentiellement
des biocarburants de 3e génération et
des e-carburants au sein d'un programme
appelé économie circulaire du carbone
donc ce programme vise finalement à la
chose suivante combinée ensemble des
sources de carbone biogéniques du CO2 de
l'eau et une source d'électricité bas
carbone pour les convertir ensemble et
produire soit des carburants soit des
produits chimiques de synthèse et pour
ça on repose sur trois grands piliers ça
peut être à la fois des procédés de
thermoconversion si on part de
ressources qui sont déjà énergétiques
par exemple du CO2 et de l'hydrogène
issue de l'électrolyse de l'eau où ça
peut être d'ajouter à de la biomasse de
l'hydrogène puisque pourquoi parce que
la biomasse contient du carbone
biogénique mais un contenu énergétique
qui n'est pas suffisant pour convertir
la totalité du carbone biogénique qui
est contenu dans la biomasse et donc
nécessaire de rajouter de l'énergie soit
sous une forme électrique soit sous une
forme d'hydrogène
et donc le CEA va s'appuyer sur toutes
ses compétences à la fois en physique en
chimie mais aussi en biologie par
exemple à travers l'utilisation de
microalgues qui vont être capable de
convertir les photos solaires en
présence d'eau et de CO2 en carburant et
la génie des procédés et va se reposer
sur ces différentes compétences pour
développer les technologies émergentes
de manière à produire des carburants
durables
à ce titre il y a un projet emblématique
que auquel le fait a participé qui est
le projet Jupiter 1000 soutenu par
l'ADEME sur le port de fosse Marseille
et qui consiste à développer une
installation de production de méthane de
synthèse à partir d'électricité
renouvelable et de CO2 via le vecteur
hydrogène qui est produit par
électrolyse de l'eau
évidemment tous ces efforts au sein du
programme économie circulaire du carbone
vise la neutralité carbone avec un
impact environnemental et sociétales
favorable pour tous les secteurs
d'activités qui sont les plus difficiles
à décarboner
donc on voit la différence de traitement
entre la partie hydrogène et la partie
biocarburant et carburant de synthèse à
travers les différents PEPR qui vont
couvrir ces activités donc le CEA
copilote avec le CNRS le PEPS sur
l'hydrogène des carbonée mais à ce jour
il n'existe pas à proprement parler un
PEP R qui est spécifiquement dédié à
l'économie circulaire du carbone en
revanche il existe deux PEPR le PEPS
spleen sur la décarbonate sur
l'industrie et le peprbest sur les bios
produits biocarburants et carburant
durable auquel le seva participe et cppr
aborde entre autres certaines questions
de R&D qui sont liées au sujet qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui les biocarburants
et les carburants de synthèse
[Musique]
sur ces différentes filières l'absence
de solutions technologiques uniques nous
impose de pousser en maturité de
nombreux concepts ce qui nécessite une
diversité de plateformes technologiques
qui vont aller du simple démonstrateur
de laboratoire à la ligne pilote et donc
au-delà des coûts d'investissement de
ces installations il nous semble
important de rappeler que leur maintien
en conditions opérationnelles
nécessitent des moyens financiers et
humains qu'il a absolument nécessaire de
prendre en compte compte tenu des temps
longs qui sont propres à la recherche et
au développement et donc le CEVA plaide
pour une réelle programmation de ces
différents investissements et de ces
conditions de fonctionnement qui
devraient être réalisées aux différentes
échelles à une échelle locale pour les
démonstrateurs de laboratoire en allant
jusqu'à l'échelle nationale quand on
parle de l'in pilote et dans ce but le
but étant évidemment de les pérenniser
et d'optimiser l'utilisation des
financements publics
un deuxième point qui convient de noter
puisque le rapporteur nous questionnait
sur les différents besoins que nous
avions identifiés pour faire émerger ces
filières c'est le fait de noter que la
maturité technologique de ces trois
filières ne leur permet pas aujourd'hui
d'être compétitive économiquement par
rapport aux énergies fossiles ce serait
beaucoup trop facile
et donc la réglementation reste un élevé
principaux pour déclencher des
investissements de long terme y compris
pour déclencher et favoriser des actions
de R&D notamment des actions
partenariales avec le tissu économique à
cette fin il est primordial que la
réglementation européenne soit stable et
soit clair
par exemple si on regarde les aides
nationales ou les aides européennes le
point de vue du CEA est qu'elle porte le
plus souvent sur le CAPEX c'est-à-dire
sur les coûts d'investissement alors que
les aides à l'OPEX sont également
extrêmement importantes par exemple afin
de garantir des prix de rachat de
l'hydrogène vert ou des e-carburants
comparativement si on regarde ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis il est vrai que
l'infection réduction Act qui a été
récemment décidé joue à la fois sur le
volet des CAPEX et sur le volet des OPEX
on notera en conséquence que quand on
regarde l'ensemble des projets qui sont
lancés à l'échelle européenne sur les
trois filières il concerne
essentiellement des projets de
démonstrateur de taille modeste en
décalage avec les scénarios
institutionnels mais aussi associatifs
qui implique des puissances de plusieurs
gigawatts
pour certains secteurs d'activité il
faut néanmoins noter que la
réglementation est parfois proactive si
on regarde le package fit for fifty-five
qui a été récemment décidé et bien il
est pratique pourquoi parce que en un
sens il ouvre une part de marché qui va
être dédiée notamment pour le transport
aérien mais aussi pour le transport
maritime si on se focalise sur le
transport aérien il prévoit que à
l'échelle 2050 63% des carburants
devront être des carburants durables
pour le transport aérien à l'intérieur
de l'Europe
28% d'ailleurs de ces carburants devront
être d'origine non biologique car il est
clair que la mobilisation de l'ensemble
des biomasses pourrait devenir un
facteur limitant et donc c'est aussi un
point de vigilance à garder en tête de
ne pas baser toute une une approche qui
mettra en oeuvre uniquement la biomasse
comme moyen de stocker l'énergie sous
une forme durable sous forme de
carburant durable
enfin si l'urgence climatique ne peut
plus être aujourd'hui nié il nous
revient d'assurer la neutralité carbone
et à cela et pour cela avoir le recours
à toutes les énergies bas carbone qu'on
pourra développer aucune solution
générique globale n'existe qui soit
soutenable à la fois économiquement et
environnementalement
l'absence d'unicité de réponse nous
impose de financer la R&D à un niveau
qui soit conséquent et au-delà des
financements qui sont évidemment
indispensables le CEA la conviction
qu'un effort de programmation systémique
et indispensable car l'ensemble des
filières industrielles de l'énergie de
cette coordonnée pour assurer cette
neutralité carbone avec le coût le
moindre possible
à ce titre ils sont importants de
rappeler qu'il peut exister et qu'il
faut prévenir des conflits d'usage à la
fois sur l'électricité bas carbone sur
l'hydrogène vert mais aussi sur la
mobilisation des ressources en biomasse
sur lesquelles s'appuie les trois
filières que nous discutons aujourd'hui
en effet quand on regarde les besoins en
énergie primaire qui vont être
nécessaire de mobiliser pour le
transport que ce soit du transport de
longue distance aérien maritime ou
toutes les formes de transport et les
autres domaines qui vont nécessiter des
carburants à base de carbone
c'est-à-dire que la chaleur a haute
température quand on additionne les
besoins on voit qu'ils peuvent rentrer
en conflit avec d'autres secteurs qui
eux aussi auront des besoins d'énergie
primaire et en particulier d'électricité
bas carbone d'hydrogène vert et de
biomasse
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
je reste bien sûr disponible pour les
questions
monsieur le rapporteur est-ce que vous
avez
une réaction ou des questions suite à
cette première intervention merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur d'abord merci de cette
présentation qui était qui était riche
alors c'est vrai que comme on vous a
donné 10 minutes et que vous êtes grosso
modo rester dans le temps vous avez
abordé beaucoup de choses de manière
relativement rapide c'est normal et puis
nous n'avons pas forcément le même degré
de la même facilité de pour jouer avec
tous ces toutes ces données là je
retiens d'abord que vous avez fait une
distinction très claire entre
biocarburant en carburant de synthèse
d'un côté et hydrogène est-ce que vous
pouvez nous repréciser pourquoi vous
faites cette différence là
un peu plus clairement que vous l'avez
fait tout à l'heure vous l'avez fait en
tout cas peut-être un peu vite pour nous
et puis deuxième point vous avez
assisté sur l'absence de solution
technologique unique aujourd'hui
et sur le fait qu'il a maturité
technologique n'était pas telle que du
point de vue économique on puisse
envisager
que tout ceci puisse être mis en oeuvre
en tout cas
actuel de l'art si je puis dire voilà
bon alors je comprends que plaidoyer
après qui consiste à dire qu'il faut
continuer les forces de recherche et
qu'il faut fixer un certain nombre de
règles ou sur le rachat ou sur etc des
OPEX et compagnies mais
nous on devrait être assez pragmatique
ici et on se dit tiens on veut faire la
transition technologique et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on vous a fait
venir grosso modo vous vous nous dites
quand même
on ne sait pas dire à quel moment on
arrivera à avoir une maturité
technologique et encore moins c'est bien
compris
quand est-ce qu'on arrivera à le faire
coïncider avec
une solution qui économiquement soit
viable bon mais alors du coup j'ai envie
de vous dire on fait comment continuer à
étudier
on a un objectif 2050 comment on est
capable de faire matcher ces calendriers
là
merci pour toutes autres questions je
vais essayer de les reprendre dans
l'ordre en essayant d'avoir tout noté
n'hésitez pas à me compléter si si
besoin en termes de de la maturité
pourquoi il y a une différenciation à
faire entre l'hydrogène les
biocarburants et les fioules c'est parce
que il y a en fait dans ces différents
concepts plusieurs déclinaisons
possibles quand on regarde l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène un premier vecteur
énergétique pour stocker l'électricité
bas carbone que l'électricités n'étant
pas stockable le stocker sous une forme
chimique donc stocker l'énergie de 60
chimique dans la liaison de l'hydrogène
c'est une façon de stocker l'énergie
après il est possible d'utiliser
l'hydrogène en tant que tel dont les
procédés industriels qui existent déjà
et qui utilisent de l'hydrogène en
particulier
le raffinage du pétrole utilise de
l'hydrogène qui est actuellement
issu de ressources fossiles la
production d'engrais en particulier
d'ammoniac via le procédé à bembauche
combine de l'azote avec de l'hydrogène
mais c'est hydrogène actuellement est
issu de ressources fossiles et dans ce
cas là la stratégie qui consisterait à
produire de l'hydrogène bas carbone et
directement l'utiliser en substitut à
des ressources pétrolières pour tous les
procédés qui utilisent l'hydrogène elle
est valable mais elle répondra pas à
tous les enjeux neutralité carbone il
faut aller plus loin parce qu'il y a
d'autres secteurs qu'il faudra aussi des
carboner et en particulier ces autres
secteurs c'est le transport
pour le transport est-ce qu'on peut
utiliser en tant que tel de l'hydrogène
si je prends un avion le problème numéro
1 de l'avion c'est lutter contre des
gravités avant d'avancer c'est lutter
contre la gravité autrement dit l'avion
sont-ils a besoin c'est de carburants
qui soient extrêmement dense en énergie
et l'hydrogène a un défaut c'est que
c'est un gaz et donc en densité par
unité de volume il répond pas à
l'équation
donc pour du transport aérien de longue
distance on utilise actuellement des
carburants liquides à base de carbone et
dans ce cas utiliser l'hydrogène comme
intermédiaire et de le fixer sur la
molécule de CO2 pour refaire des
carburants de synthèse typiquement des
kérosêmes de synthèse bah ça c'est une
façon de répondre à ce besoin sectoriel
de l'aviation d'accord c'est une
maturité technologique qui est qui reste
à développer puisque actuellement c'est
kérosène il y a certains procédés qui
existent à partir d'hydrogène mais ils
ont pas une maturité quand on utilise du
CO2 et l'hydrogène ensemble donc c'est
quelque chose qui va arriver qu'il faut
développer en ce qui concerne les
biocarburants les biocarburants il y a
plusieurs générations de biocarbures si
vous utilisez une biomasse qui produit
des sucres tels que la betterave
derrière vous pouvez transformer votre
sucre en étalonne et en éthanol pardon
et faire des biocarburants de première
génération avec un conflit potentiel
d'usage entre l'alimentation et le
secteur de l'énergie la deuxième
génération va plutôt utiliser des
déchets la troisième génération ne
rentre pas du tout en compétition avec
les filières alimentaires pourquoi parce
qu'il s'agit d'utiliser des micro-algues
que vous allez faire pousser dans des
dans des photos du réacteurs dédiées qui
vont combiner directement du CO2 de
l'eau et le flux solaire pour aller
faire des huiles que vous pouvez
raffiner derrière en biocarburant donc
il est important de regarder ces
différentes générations parce qu'elle
pose elles ont des niveaux de maturité
différents la première génération est
plus mature que la deuxième qui est plus
mature que la troisième mais elle pose
des contraintes en termes de
sollicitations des différentes
ressources qui sont différentes donc il
faut faire une déclinaison entre les
différentes générations de biocarburant
enfin les fuel les fuel finalement
utilisent le CO2 qui est une molécule
extrêmement stable et c'est bien pour ça
qu'elle s'accumule dans l'atmosphère
parce qu'elle réagit mal elle réagit peu
elle est complètement dépourvue
d'énergie et du coup il faudra ajouter
beaucoup d'hydrogène ou beaucoup
d'électricité en amont pour aller
convertir ce CO2 et donc comme c'est
plus gourmand en énergie votre rendement
énergétique total il est plus faible et
du coup il faut vraiment déployer ces
solutions là où on a encore besoin de
carburant durable
si je prends le cas du véhicule
électrique est-ce bien intelligente
d'utiliser un véhicule électrique un
véhicule pardon qui utiliserait des
carburants durables sachant que produire
des carburants durables utiliseraient
plus d'électricité bas carbone plutôt
qu'une solution qui mettra en jeu une
batterie si le rendement énergétique de
la batterie est que l'Analyse de Cycle
de Vie global nous dit que c'est plus
intéressant de faire la batterie il faut
aller sur la batterie
pour l'avion encore une fois le premier
numéro 1 et qui reste dans les airs et
là on a peu de solutions technologiques
on est obligé d'aller vers des
carburants qui soient durables
et ça ça se reflète très bien au niveau
européen parce qu'on voit qu'il y a deux
ipcei qui sont sur les filières
hydrogène et il n'y a pas encore d'ipcoi
par exemple qui existe sur les filières
de biocarburant carburant de synthèse
donc on voit ces différences de maturité
qui apparaît
si
[Musique]
donc je vais passer la parole à
Jean-Philippe Perrault je vais qui est
responsable des programmes biomasse vers
carburant vert VRS à l'IFP énergie
nouvelle monsieur héros vous avez la
parole merci président bonjour à tous
donc j'ai un petit mot rapide sur IFP
énergie nouvelle donc c'est un organisme
public de recherche et innovation
j'insiste sur le terme innovation notre
ADN à l'IFP c'est de porter et énergie
nouvelle c'est de porter une idée du
laboratoire vers un marché et donc c'est
vraiment d'aller chercher à valoriser
notre recherche et on valorise notre
recherche notamment par la vente par
notre filiale absence qui va vendre des
licences à différents industriels dans
le monde
c'est une longue histoire on a développé
il y a plus de 40 ans les premières
générations de biocarburant qui viennent
d'être cités par Monsieur Cantat la
partie biocarburant que l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui à la pompe
issus d'huile de colza ou dessus des
betteraves notamment pour la France donc
le 10 BZ que vous avez à la pompe sont
des carburants de première génération
dont l'IFP a fait la recherche dans les
années
80-90 depuis maintenant une vingtaine
d'années
une dizaine d'années
IFP
a développé ou accès sa recherche sur
les carburants avancés
nous quand on dit carburant avancé c'est
donc issu de biomasse qui ne rentre pas
en compétition avec l'alimentation
humaine et animale
donc pour ça on a on va dire mis trois
procédés à l'échelle industrielle donc
un premier procédé qui reprend des
huiles de cuisson usagée des grasses
animales donc qui correspond à l'hydro
traitement de charge lipidique donc
c'est des procédés qui sont proches de
ce qui peut être trouvé dans le
raffinage conventionnel l'énergie de
carburant de pétrole et donc qui a un
niveau de maturité relativement élevé
qui ont nécessité un développement en
termes de temps plus réduit et qui sont
aujourd'hui industriels donc à titre
d'exemple on peut citer une première
référence en France avec l'unité de La
Mède qui a été construite par poids
total énergie donc dans le sud de la
France et une dizaine de licences à
travers de le monde sur cette voie de
production de biocarburant à partir de
charge lipidique
d'autres projets sont venus compléter
cette partie
de développement sur les biocarburants
avancés donc on va distinguer deux voix
une voix qui va nous permettre de
produire un peu carburant qui va être
incorporable à de l'essence donc
typiquement de l'éthanol et là on va
parler du projet futural futural c'est
11 ans de recherche on se partenaire et
un budget de 80 millions 10 millions
d'euros le projet s'est arrêté dans les
années 2018 et donc il est aujourd'hui
disponible industriels et commercial ça
fait l'objet de deux unités de
démonstration basée une apomacle vers
Reims et l'autre abusit le Lot à côté de
race également qui nous ont permis de
dérisquer la technologie de production
d'éthanol à partir de biomasse Dino
cellulosique quand on parle de
biomassinoscillosique on parle de résidu
forestier et du réside de bois et donc
passer de bois à d'éthanol ça nécessite
différents traitements chimiques
qui nécessitent d'être développé à
l'échelle du laboratoire
de d'être dé risqué à un échelle de
démonstrateur de façon à avoir un
procédé viable industriellement la voie
futurale est une voie biochimique c'est
à dire qu'on va utiliser des enzymes qui
vont venir attaquer la
biomasseurique pour aller chercher des
sucres contenant la biomasse et on va
fermenter ensuite ces sucres pour
pouvoir former l'éthanol
l'éthanol on peut l'incorporer dans
l'essence aujourd'hui une autre voie de
valorisation de l'éthanol et la
production de jet à partir des éthanol
par la voie alcool to jet qui est une
voie certifiée et qui peut être
incorporée à hauteur de 50% dans les
aéronefs
une deuxième façon de produire des
biocarbures avancés
c'est avec de sauce qui va s'orienter
vers plutôt les carburants de type
gazole et kérosène par la voie
fishertropsh donc la matière première
sera la même cela sera des risques du
lino cellulosique donc des résidus
agricoles et forestiers
qui vont passer par une étape cette fois
de traitement thermochimiques à haute
température
1500° on va former à gazeux un gaz de
synthèse ce gaz de synthèse c'est du
monoxyde de carbone CO et d'hydrogène va
être ensuite recombé par le procédé
fischertrops on va ainsi produire une
variabilité de produits donc depuis
l'essence jusqu'au gazole avec des
propriétés de carburant qui sont premium
c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont pas de soufre
qui n'ont pas d'aromatiques donc qui ne
forment pas de il n'y a pas de
précurseur de particules dans ces
carburants qui sont donc de haute
qualité
cette technologie ce projet c'est
beautiful beautiful a été
développé accès partenaire c'est 11
années de recherche et c'est terminé en
2021 et c'est 200 millions de budget
l'unité a été le projet a fait l'objet
de deux unités de démonstration une
avenette pour la partie et une à
Dunkerque
et c'est devenu Nutella ont permis de la
même façon que le projet Futura de
dérisquer toutes les étapes de la
technologie pour passer de l'échappe de
l'étape laboratoire à l'échelle
industrielle sur ces deux projets là
ont reçu des subventions de la part de
l'État français à hauteur de 30 millions
environ pour les deux projets
la technologie beautiful aujourd'hui
l'IFP avec ses partenaires ont monté un
projet dans le cadre de l'appel à projet
carba héros
est reçu à travers le projet beauty jet
la valorisation et la volonté de
continuer l'aventure beautiful vers
l'échelle industrielle à travers le
projet beauty jet donc qui a vocation
d'être la première unité de production
de carburant de type SAF en France
donc ça a été annoncé notamment il y a à
peu près une dizaine de jours lors de la
réunions ministérielle sur les lauréats
du Descartes aéro de l'appel à projet
concernant les i carburants
les carburants comme ça a été cité juste
avant c'est environ 4 étapes certaines
étapes sont matures dans la brique
technologique on va parler du captage du
CO2 et là faudra se poser la question de
l'origine du captage du CO2 de l'origine
du CO2 du CO2 atmosphérique versus CO2
industriel ou le CO2 fatal donc ça c'est
un enjeu aussi pour les industriels de
avoir cette molécule de carbone et
l'origine de cette molécule de carbone
et la facilité d'obtention est
différente et l'étape de synthèse
fischertrops qu'on a cité juste avant
qu'il y ait une brique de la technologie
beautiful qui a été développée à l'IFP
depuis les années 2000 sont deux
procédés matures la pâte électrolyse on
pourrait considérer aujourd'hui que
c'est un procédé mature également mais
qui va nécessiter d'énormes
investissements pour la production des
électrolyseurs et des capacités
d'électrolyseurs à court échéance et
donc il y a un enjeu sur la partie
électronique sur la fabrication puisque
sur la partie R&D même si sur la partie
R&D il y a toujours des amélior façon de
procéder à faire
la brique la plus complexe et qui
nécessite encore du développement c'est
la partie transformation du CO2 en CO
donc éliminer un atome d'oxygène pour
retrouver une molécule qui retrouve de
la réalité le monoxyde de carbone sur
lequel on va venir derrière greffer
l'hydrogène pour faire des carburants de
synthèse donc cette brique River soit
orga Shift est encore aujourd'hui à
l'échelle du développement et va
nécessiter encore quelques
mois avant d'arriver à l'échelle
industrielle
si on parle d'hydrogène aujourd'hui une
bonne combinaison comme c'était si tu es
juste avant et de combiner l'hydrogène
avec unité de type BTL biomasse tous les
quid pourquoi parce qu'en combinant
cette hydrogène avec du carbone
biogénique on va pouvoir maximiser le
rendement de la chaîne et donc ainsi
valoriser au maximum la ressource
biomasse pour la production carburant
et quand on connaît ou quand on y a le
débat sur la disponibilité de la
biomasse apportée de l'hydrogène et puis
valoriser le maximum de la biomasse ça
représente un intérêt et en même temps
c'est un moyen de mettre de l'hydrogène
dans un aéronef par exemple dans un
environnement sécurisé qui dispose d'une
logistique et déjà existante dans un
carburant dense donc l'hydrogène on fait
le porter quelque part par le carbone
en conclusion ce qu'on pourrait dire
c'est que on a la maturité technologique
pour produire des carburants
des biocarburants avancés aujourd'hui la
maturité technologique est là les
procédés ont été développés et démontrés
à l'échelle pré-industrielle et
aujourd'hui on doit passer à la partie
déploiement de ces technologies pour
pouvoir aller sur le pour pouvoir
répondre à l'objectif 2030 et 2050 de
production de carburant de biocarburant
la France a des atouts elle dispose de
la ressource agricole et forestière
la France a un écosystème industriel
donc on a un savoir-faire dans la
production de carburant dans le site
industriels sont déjà présents et on a
développé des technologies
issues d'une propre travaux français de
recherche donc on a aussi sous sa voix
de faire technologique on a cette
connaissance pour pouvoir faire les
par contre maintenant faut passer au
déploiement et pour déploiement et on
considère qu'il y a principalement trois
enjeux structurer la filière
d'approvisionnement de la ressource
souvent quand on dit et quand on voit à
travers certains projets qu'il faut
faire un projet industriel c'est la
partie unité et production mais c'est
aussi un vrai projet pour aller récolter
la ressource chercher la ressource et la
porter au pied de pied de l'unité donc
c'est presque deux projets
le deuxième point c'est le soutien
l'investissement ça a été évoqué juste
avant avec le soutien aux apex donc le
soutien en CAPEX c'est un point
important ce sont des millions qui sont
en jeu sur la partie investissement et
le soutien l'investissement permet à
l'industriel de réduire son risque par
rapport à différentes étapes du projet
et enfin une réglementation stable dans
le temps donc ça c'est important aussi
pour un industriel d'avoir quelque chose
qui est stable de façon à ne pas avoir
de mauvaises surprises on va dire dans
le développement et dans la valorisation
des produits qui pourra avoir
je rajouterai à la fin qui faut pas
opposer les filières faut pas se dire on
va tous les secteurs vont avoir besoin
dans tous les cas demain on aura besoin
d'un mix énergétique pour pouvoir
répondre à la demande des transports
il ne faut pas opposer les différentes
filières les unes aux autres font que
toutes les filières s'associent de façon
à pouvoir faire dénudées les plus
importantes possibles et réduire les
coûts de production associés
et on est capable avec ces procédés là
de pouvoir diriger les produits vers
différents marchés aux différents
secteurs que ça soit le transport
terrestre ou aéronautique
merci sur un porteur
merci gros je vais très bref parce que
votre peau était c'est clair vous vous
insistez surtout sur le besoin de passer
au déploiement avec l'idée que la
maturité est plutôt là sur les points
que vous avez évoqué c'est ce que je
retiens complètement sur la voie pour la
biocarburant avancée à que ce soit par
la voie biochimique ou thermochimique la
maturité technologique existe
aujourd'hui a été démontré à l'échelle
près industrielle
là et la question du volume potentiel de
la capacité à à terme de développement
en termes de volume de coûts
du coup du coup et de volume alors les
volumes donc c'est quelque part la
disponibilité de la ressource quand on
dit les volumes envisagés donc il y a
des études qui a été faite par impérial
College en 2021 qui montre que le
potentiel biomasse en France existe pour
produire une quantité suffisante de
biocarburant avancé
donc le potentiel est là après il faut
aller chercher cette biomasse cette
biomasse là et donc c'est là l'enjeu ou
du structurer la filière pour pouvoir
récupérer
les bonnes quantités nécessaires sans
appauvrir les sols non plus voilà il y a
toute une réflexion qui qui a été faite
aussi une impériale collège il n'a pas
considéré que 100% de la biomasse était
récupérable était récupérable donc ça
c'est présent
pour la partie coup aujourd'hui ça a été
dit par mon prédécesseur
et puis on voit bien les entre du bois
et un carburant liquide
les étapes de transformation sont
beaucoup plus complexes qu'entre du
pétrole brut et du un carburant
conventionnel donc forcément il y aura
un coup supplémentaire pour pouvoir
porter cette charge renouvelable vers du
carburant et ça c'est un coût qu'il y a
l'investissement et c'est là où si
toutes les personnes tous les secteurs
s'associent pour
déployer ces voies là on va pouvoir
réduire aussi les coûts avec aussi
l'avancement de la maturité
technologique des premières unités
industrielles qui vont nous permettre
aussi d'acquérir de l'expérience et de
bénéficier de ce retour d'expérience sur
les sur les unités qui seront
constituent à terme les autres unités
si je Monsieur Pascal bain qui est
responsable du département Sciences
Physiques l'ingénieur et chimie énergie
à l'Agence nationale de la recherche
vous intervenez en visio est-ce que vous
nous entendez
est-ce que nous est-ce qu'on vous entend
a priori on n'a pas de
il y a pas le retour vers nous
on vous entend parfaitement merci
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président donc
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
Messieurs les parlementaires mesdames
messieurs tout d'abord je voulais un peu
rappeler ce qu'est la NR je tiens
d'abord à vous remercier pour votre
invitation à participer à cette table
ronde dans le cadre de cette mission
d'information donc la NR comme vous le
savez sans doute c'est l'agence publique
de financement de la recherche sur
projet en France qui soutient l'ensemble
des domaines scientifiques et
accompagnent les recherches
fondamentales ou appliquées de niveau de
maturité technologique variées mais en
général relativement bas puisqu'on a un
positionnement qui est complémentaire de
celui d'autres agences comme par exemple
l'ADEME qu'on a déjà cité précédemment
ou BPI France au plan national mais
également à travers du cofinancement de
projets européens ou internationaux
et notamment la NR soutient des équipes
de recherche des organismes de recherche
publique dont on vient d'entendre les
propos par exemple le CEA ou l'IFPEN ont
été impliqués dans nombre de projets
qu'on a soutenus dans le passé et qu'on
continue à soutenir aujourd'hui sur ces
différentes filières sur lesquelles je
reviendrai tout à l'heure et puis
également bien entendu dépendant
d'autres organismes comme le CNRS qu'on
va entendre tout à l'heure des
universités des grandes écoles et mais
également des entreprises qu'elles
soient petites moyennes ou grande
je voulais également rappeler que la NR
en fait est aussi un des quatre grands
opérateurs de France 2030 qui est la
bannière qui regroupe l'ensemble des
anciens programmes qu'on appelait donc
programme d'investissement d'avenir avec
donc BPI France d'une part la Caisse des
dépôts des territoires et la dette et à
ce titre l'agence prend en charge
l'organisation de la sélection du
conventionnement du financement du suivi
des audits de l'évaluation et de
l'impact des projets qui sont financés
dans ce cadre et dans lequel en fait
elle a cette responsabilité et qui sont
notamment un certain nombre d'actions
positionnées dans le soutien à la
recherche à bon je définirais tout à
l'heure
et aujourd'hui
principalement dans le cadre des
stratégies nationales d'accélération
dont le volet Hamon est décliné sous la
forme de PEPR dont on a entendu le signe
donc programme et équipements
prioritaire de recherche
puisqu'il existe un PEPR dédié à
l'hydrogène décarbonée correspondant à
la cette stratégie nationale pour je
suis en fait responsable de la mise en
oeuvre côté à NR sachant que ce p.epr
est piloté d'une part par le CEA d'autre
part par le CNRS et également d'autres
PEP R qui ont déjà été mentionnés
également qui traite d'une part des
carburants annoncés même si c'est pas la
totalité de CEP puisqu'il s'occupe
globalement en fait des différentes
usages des ressources en biomass et
d'autre part la décarbonation de
l'industrie dans laquelle on retrouve
notamment un projet portant sur les i
carburants carburant
également dessus voilà donc je vais pas
répéter ce que l'on dit mais deux
prédécesseurs du CES ifpel comme je l'ai
dit donc l'agence un positionnement un
petit peu différent dans la mesure où
elle n'est pas opérateur de recherche et
là un rôle de soutien aux équipes de
recherche qui déposent des projets à des
appels que l'on cela NR notamment des
appels ouverts et qui vont permettre de
soutenir des projets à l'initiative des
établissements des chercheurs s'y tenter
que les idées soient bonnes et les
projets soient de qualité
les projets sont évalués par le principe
des pères pour que des chercheurs
principalement qui exercent dans ces
domaines alors je vais quand même
revenir un peu sur l'historique du
soutien de la NR à dire puisqu'en fait
en commençant par les biocarburant ce
qui va me permettre aussi de peut-être
mettre l'accent de nouveau sur les
degrés de maturité les différentes
filières c'est un point qui est
particulièrement important on a vu en
commençant par les biocarbures
effectivement
c'est une filière qui présente pour
certains aspects et notamment donc on a
mentionné la deuxième génération un
degré de maturité qui est assez avancé
aujourd'hui effectivement avec des
résultats par exemple autour du
démonstrateur qui avait été financé par
l'ADEME dans le cadre du faux Grenelle
de l'environnement donc Futurol mais je
tenais à souligner que en fait ce
démonstrateur Futurol s'était appuyé sur
des travaux qui avaient été réalisés
notamment dans le de projet à NR je
pourrais donner la liste ici c'est
peut-être pas le l'endroit mais je vous
la donnerai dans le compte rendu que je
vous ferai de réponse à vos questions
une liste d'un certain nombre de projets
qui avaient été soutenus par la NR sur
des briques technologiques spécifiques
que ce soit pour déconstruire la
biomasse puisqu'on a dit que c'était une
des étapes clés au départ on part de la
biomasse il faut la déconstruire pour
avoir accès aux différentes ressources
mais également des voix de
transformation des différentes pour
aller jusqu'au produit final et donc ces
briques technologiques avaient été
financées dans le cadre de différents
projets par la NR pour ensuite mener à
la création sous démonstrateur voilà
donc on perçoit aujourd'hui le potentiel
avec la mise sur le marché du produit
qui en est issu
sur les trois générations notamment qui
font appel à des micro-organismes tels
des micro-algues là encore la NR les a
soutenu très tôt puisque en fait dès
2007 la dernière je rappelle a été créé
en 2016 c'était au menu de sa
programmation donc on était parmi des
premiers à soutenir ce type de projet là
et c'est quelque chose qu'on a soutenu
un peu dans la continuité
ces travaux portant sur l'utilisation du
micro-organismes et des micro-algues
pour arriver à des carburants dans la
mesure où aujourd'hui c'est probablement
du côté des biocarburants la filière
pour laquelle il y a encore le plus
besoin de travaux et ça fait d'ailleurs
l'objet d'un des deux projets ciblés du
PEPR qui porte sur les carburants
d'origine biologique donc qui est
précisément consacré à développer des
recherches autour de ces micros
sur l'hydrogène des carbonées là encore
l'ANR a mis en place des sacréation un
programme de recherche ambitieux puisque
en fait ce programme a permis de
financer pour un montant des passants
100 millions d'euros sur les six
premiers années d'existence de l'agence
un certain nombre de projets
plus de 120 projets voilà
sur les différentes briques
technologiques alors en grande partie
focalisée sur l'électrolyse notamment
pour la production d'hydrogène bien
entendu
notamment l'électrolyse température mais
aussi des projets sur l'électrolyse
haute température avec une application
très forte du CEA qui ont notamment mené
à la création de d'entreprises telles
par exemple ou encore genevia dont on
devient dont on parlait qui a été créé
il y a un peu plus d'un an et demi
sur les autres aspects de l'hydrogène on
a bien entendu aussi beaucoup financé de
projets notamment sur des technologies
qui sont moins matures aujourd'hui sur
le stockage d'hydrogène sous forme
solide sachant que là encore il y a
différentes technologies possibles le
stockage sous forme liquide étant
probablement la plus mature aujourd'hui
le stockage à haute pression
étant également une technologie qui
pourrait être mise sur le marché très
rapidement s'il y avait vraiment des
marchés pour cela même si il y a encore
des projets de recherche qui sont
financés ces sujets là
le troisième sujet donc je vais aborder
donc c'est celui des carburants de type
8 carburant voir carburant solaire dont
on n'a pas encore parlé
qui est comme ça a été mentionné
précédemment probablement globalement la
moins mature des trois filières
les premiers projets que j'ai vu à la NR
financé donc tourné autour de quand les
voix de valorisation du CO2 puisque
c'était comme cela qu'on les percevait à
l'époque avec des projets qui ont été
financés dès 2010 donc ce qui est ça
remonte déjà à quelques années mais
c'est même très tôt par rapport à toute
la dynamique en termes de recherche qui
s'est plutôt engagé dans les années qui
ont suivi donc les premiers projets
c'était que financé par la NR sur ces
questions là qui d'ailleurs appliquaient
les entreprises telles que engie EDF à
l'époque total
dès 2009-2010 sur l'étude des
perspectives
de fabriquer des carburants à partir
principalement de la voie électronique
par électrolyse donc à l'époque
tout cela c'est poursuivi encore
aujourd'hui donc régulièrement chaque
année la NR finance des projets sur ces
sujets là avec
beaucoup en fait ce club sert une grande
créativité de la part des chercheurs
puisque en fait comme c'est une
technologie qui est parmi les moins
matures et notamment celle qui vise à
utiliser directement l'énergie solaire
pour produire des molécules de type
carburant que ce soit du méthane du
methanol voir des composés plus avancés
directement à partir des ressources
solaires par des processus photo
électrochimiques c'est certainement la
voix
éventuellement comme un Graal qui est la
moins avancée technologiquement et sur
laquelle en fait la NR apporte des
financements pour pouvoir explorer le
plus de voix possible sachant que bien
entendu
comme toujours en termes de recherche il
faut poser au départ sur beaucoup de
voix pour être sur ou à peu près sûr que
il y en a quelques-unes qui arrivent à
émerger à passer à un stade de TRL qu'on
appelle le trl4 à un moment donné qui
est le moment où la technologie va
sortir du laboratoire va pouvoir passer
à une échelle de pilote ou de la du
laboratoire les avant cela il y a
beaucoup de d'échecs qui est tout à fait
normal en terme de recherche et c'est
aussi des enjeux de la NR c'est de
pouvoir soutenir le plus de voix
possible exploratoire pour être sûr
qu'au final il y en a quelques unes qui
arrivent à déboucher comme cela avait pu
être fait sur les exemples que j'ai
donné précédemment que ce soit sur une
technologie d'hydrogène ou dans le
domaine des biocarburant
voilà donc on pollinaire que je pourrais
compléter soit au niveau des questions
soit
si Monsieur bain chevet passer la parole
à Monsieur Alexandre le gris qui est
directeur adjoint scientifique de
l'Institut de chimie du Centre national
de la recherche scientifique vous avez
la parole
merci pour votre invitation merci de
m'accueillir ici dans ce lieu très très
marqué par l'histoire et aussi par
l'avenir
je veux vous exposer un petit peu le
fonctionnement du CNRS qui est un peu
différent de celui qui a été
évoqué par mes
prédécesseurs et néanmoins tout à fait
complémentaire puisque notre travaillant
sur le terrain main dans la main
plus près avec les collègues du CEA dans
de nombreuses unités que l'on porte avec
eux une themix mais aussi dans nos
unités que l'on porte avec des
universités on a beaucoup de
collaborations avec le CA aussi avec les
Pen le fonctionnement du général c'est
un petit peu différent c'est à dire que
nous on travaille pas sur projet vous
savez que le chercheur en France tient
son indépendance et nous nous tenons à
ce que à ce qu'elle puisse être maintenu
parce qu'on pense qu'elle est créatrice
de de la liberté créatrice de créatrice
tout simplement
et néanmoins dans le domaine qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui le CNRS amené ces
dernières années un certain nombre
d'actions de
de création de communauté dans le
domaine de l'hydrogène
le CNRS a permis la création de ce que
l'on appelle aujourd'hui une fédération
de recherche nationale qui regroupe une
trentaine de laboratoires disséminés
dans l'ensemble du territoire sur
l'ensemble du territoire et cette
fédération de recherche et un des
acteurs majeurs de du PEP hydrogène que
nous comportant avec le CEA donc c'est
un sorte de préfigurateur côté CNRS de
ce PEP et donc les domaines qui sont
traitées dans cette fédération de
recherche couvre
l'ensemble de la des activités en lien
avec la production propre de l'hydrogène
avec aussi l'utilisation l'hydrogène
comme vecteur de transport avec
l'utilisation des piles à combustibles
et aussi de le domaine de stockage de
l'hydrogène certains ont été
on travaille aussi sur des recherches
dont on parle de stockage sous forme
solide par solution solide dans des
métaux par exemple
on est aussi sur le sur ce qu'on appelle
les systèmes c'est-à-dire agrégé un
certain nombre de unités de base pour
pour faire des
systèmes qui fonctionnent pour aussi
bien l'électrolyse que pour
l'inverse c'est-à-dire pour la
utilisation de des piles à combustibles
ces recherches là sont très
complémentaires ou un petit peu parfois
on amende de ce qui a été évoqué par mon
collègue du CEA et on travaille en toute
bonne intelligence avec sur l'ensemble
du territoire dans le domaine des bio
que carburants le scénariste a aussi
possédé au milieu des années 2000 2010 à
la création d'une fédération nationale
qui s'appelle une crise qui travaille
sur les biocarburants
et donc et les carburants
issus de la biomasse ils sont
étudiés aussi vient du point de vue des
procédés
que aussi de solutions innovantes
donc ça concerne aussi un volant
important de chercheurs et d'anciens
chercheurs disséminés sur le territoire
le CNRS n'est pas porteur du PEP qui
s'occupe des biocarburants mais c'est
pas tout à fait c'est pas grave je pense
que nous avons quand même des équipes
qui sont impliquées et pour ce qui
concerne
les
icarburants
le CNRS participe
au PEP décarbonation de l'industrie donc
on a des équipes notamment à Lyon qui
pilotent un des projets ciblés et nous
sommes toujours un petit peu en amont de
ce qui se fait en termes de de
de filière industrielle pour essayer de
développer des solutions innovantes nos
équipes travaillent évidemment sur la
sur la capture de CO2 par exemple la
capture et la valorisation du CO2 sous
différentes formes valorisation soit pas
par électrochimie mais aussi par le la
photo catalyse ou des choses comme ça
c'est-à-dire l'objectif est de se
défricher le terrain comme ça a été dit
par Monsieur vin pour voir après dans ce
terrain qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir sortir
en termes de filières industriels donc
le chercheur CNRS
comme je le dis travail en toute liberté
ces dernières années il y a quand même
un infléchissement c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a des programmes nationaux qui qui ont
été mis en place par la LPR et notamment
ses fameux PEP programme d'équipements
prioritaire de recherche qui permettent
de structurer des filières et de
filières de recherche longtemps de
structurer plutôt des communautés qui
vont travailler ensemble
pour développer des solutions innovantes
dans un domaine de recherche qui est
très varié on parlait de chimie mais on
parle aussi de
biochimie ça a été évoqué que que
qu'elle va être la chimie de demain
est-ce que on va utiliser toujours les
procédés quand ils jouent aujourd'hui
mais dans certains domaines on voit que
l'utilisation des enzymes et la
programmation des enzymes c'est des
domaines dans lequel le scénariste
travaille aussi de concert avec nos
partenaires peut être aussi peu
constituer des solutions alternatives
intéressantes et importante pour la
production des molécules d'intérêts de
demain qui peut faire aussi bien des
biocarburants que des
que des matériaux par exemple
voilà
merci beaucoup
sur le rapporteur
pour moi on a auditionné tout le monde
monsieur chers collègues
bien ok du point de vue du
CNRS là vous avez insisté sur la
structuration des communautés de
recherche après qu'elle regarde vous
portez sur la sur la maturité de
de toutes ces directions de recherche
alors vous avez peut-être me dire vous
êtes moins dans le développement
mais voilà quel est votre regard oui oui
et non le CNRS a depuis quelques années
une politique de maturation et de
prématuration très importante
moi je dirais que il y a deux choses qui
ont été dites par mes prédécesseurs à
laquelle on nous souscrivant d'une part
c'est clair que transformer la matière
partir de de matière basse énergie pour
l'amener vers la haute énergie ça a un
coût et ça a aussi un rendement ça a été
ça a été évoqué donc il y a un prix
souvent à payer pour passer ce col
énergétique si j'ose dire et
donc qu'est-ce qui peut compenser ce
surcoût c'est bien entendu la
réglementation c'est clair que
aujourd'hui si on pouvait continuer à
utiliser le pétrole ce serait évidemment
le moins cher mais je pense qu'on est
tous à peu près convaincu que c'est
c'est pas une voix qui qui est très
durable et donc il va falloir il y a un
surcoût à assurer
aussi je pense que les communautés
scientifiques c'est des citoyens donc
les gens sont de plus en plus convaincus
et donc il y a pas que
ces thématiques qui sont très sociétales
interface donc entre notre mode de vie
et la science attire aussi et permettent
aussi structurer la communauté et puis
après moi ce que j'ai entendu c'est
qu'on a affaire à des à des technologies
qui ont une certaine maturité après
c'est une question de surcoût et de coût
d'installation j'ai entendu parler de
CAPEX et d'OPEX je pense que c'est des
choses aussi
qui sont importantes
c'est bon pour vous monsieur
Martine Berthet
oui merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup messieurs pour
ces éléments c'est vrai qu'on voit qu'il
y a une recherche qui apporte plein de
possibilités et que c'est pour ça que je
dis toujours qu'il faut garder espoir en
France on a beaucoup de chercheurs et de
bons chercheurs donc voilà trouvons des
solutions par contre comme vous l'avez
dit ensuite il faut pouvoir amener la
biomasse enfin la organiser toute la
filière alors justement comment
travailler vous avec les entreprises
ensuite parce que quel lien faites-vous
vous vous êtes sur la recherche mais
derrière qu'est-ce qui est mis en oeuvre
pour que alors les entreprises peut-être
aussi les les laboss de recherche de
certains groupes industriels comment
comment faites-vous le lien
tu associes
alors du côté du CEA tout est tiré en
fait par la maturité technologique c'est
à dire que si on est sur de la maturité
technologique basse donc de la recherche
de laboratoire amont on va être
essentiellement sur de la recherche
partenariale avec le tissu académique
par contre évidemment dès que vous
montez en maturité technologique là
c'est vraiment le tissu industriel qui
est le meilleur relais et donc il y a
deux grands types de fonctionnement soit
la recherche bilatérale qui est la plus
propice au transfert industriel donc là
évidemment il y a intérêt directement de
l'industriel et le but c'est d'aller
faire du transfert technologique donc le
mode bilatéral est privilégié et puis
quand vous êtes dans une zone un petit
peu ce qu'on appelle la vallée de la
mort de l'innovation c'est à dire vous
êtes en train d'explorer cette montée
enterl vous êtes pas encore sur quelque
chose qui est suffisamment mature et ben
là vous pouvez avoir une recherche
partenariale à travers des financements
institutionnels que ce soit au niveau
national ou au niveau européen qui vous
permettent justement d'avoir un lien
privilégié avec un industriel mais un
risque qui est amorti justement par des
financements institutionnels donc c'est
vraiment ça ça dépend de la maturité
technologique ce qu'on va explorer c'est
extrêmement important de répondre la
réglementation en fait on peut croire
que la réglementation n'est qu'un moteur
pour le développement industriel en
réalité c'est aussi à travers ces liens
entre le tissu industriel et le tissu de
la recherche c'est aussi un moteur pour
l'aider pourquoi parce que il est
évident du point de vue industriel quand
vous avez une réglementation qui se
durcit qui se précise qui est incitative
que ils vont se tourner vers le tissu de
la recherche pour trouver des solutions
parce que vous avez une nouvelle
contrainte qui s'impose à vous qui est
plus juste une contrainte strictement
économique de la compétition économique
vous avez une nouvelle contrainte qui va
s'imposer à vous et du coup vous avez
besoin d'idation de création de
nouvelles solutions technologiques qui
doivent autant en maturité et donc ça
aussi c'est un très bon driver pour la
R&D on n'a pas beaucoup répondu à la
question que vous avez tous posé sur
l'aspect économique parce que c'est
extrêmement difficile on est plutôt des
opérateurs de recherche donc on n'a pas
à vocation à
chiffrer de façon précise quel est le
prix d'un e-carburant quel est le prix
d'un biocarburant ça dépend énormément
des conditions par contre on peut quand
même donner un ordre de grandeur parce
que c'est bon de l'avoir en tête je
regretterai qu'on sorte de cette pièce
on vous ayez un ordre de grandeur en
tête typiquement quand on est sur un
carburant durable on parle de quelque
chose qui est 3 4 fois plus cher que le
carburant issu de fossile mais attention
le service rendu n'est pas du tout le
même un carburant issu de fossiles vous
êtes en train de puiser dans des
ressources épuisables vous accumulez du
CO2 fossile dans l'atmosphère un
carburant durable justement ne va pas
puiser dans des ressources assez
puissables c'est bien le but et ne va
pas le but c'est qu'il soit neutre en
carbone du point de vue de la
réglementation européenne c'est qu'il
soit qui produit 70% de moins de CO2 que
l'équivalent fossile donc il soit bien
moins émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
et c'est là le surcoût le 3 le facteur 3
4 il vient de là d'accord c'est pas que
la maturité technologique des
technologies parce qu'en fait les
technologies sont extrêmement
différentes c'est bien du fait que le
service rendu à la fin est différent par
exemple ce qu'il faudrait comparer c'est
combien ça coûterait un carburant sur
lequel vous imposez de capter et de
stocker de CO2 par rapport à un
carburant durable l'un resterait
complètement linéaire épuiserait des
sources fossiles et puiseraient des
capacités de stockage mais il aura un
service rendu qui n'aimait pas de CO2 à
la fin dans l'atmosphère et peut-être
déjà là on pourrait commencer à comparer
avec un carburant durable et tout de
suite vous verriez que Ben ce facteur 3
4 en fait c'est complètement similaire
merci Monsieur
pour la partie ressources dans les
projets qu'on a développés on a toujours
fait attention à cette à cette partie là
ressources et on a développé des
technologies qui étaient multiro-sources
justement pas pour s'associer à une
seule à une seule type de charge du bois
ou de la paille par exemple
avec vous la vocation de pouvoir
déployer la technologie
à travers le monde donc on a toujours on
a eu des acteurs de la ressource dans
les projets qui ont été portés dans ces
deux projets là qui ont sur lequel on a
fait une cartographie pour balayer les
différents types de ressources qui ont
été testés sur nos unités de
démonstration de façon à évaluer les
différences entre les ressources et les
adaptations technologiques à faire après
quand on parle de ressources en termes
de territoires là c'est vraiment un
projet industriel qui va s'attacher à la
ressource au niveau local et à
l'écosystème local pour récupérer la
ressource donc en général les rayons de
collecte qui sont aujourd'hui
amis pour une autour d'unité de
production de biocarburant c'est aux
alentours de 200 km au-delà il y a des
effets qui sont directs sur la partie
émission de CO2 et comme l'a dit
Monsieur Cantat et donc c'est
le respect de la réglementation que l'on
doit avoir
monsieur ben est-ce que vous nous
entendez
vous voulez réagir oui merci
de la parole je vais essayer de répondre
à la question de Madame sur le lien
entre recherche et industriel et les
relations qu'on peut avoir ou faciliter
pour le transfert alors tout d'abord une
remarque préliminaire sur ce point-là
c'est que pour avoir discuté avec pas
mal de
directeurs de la recherche ou le
directeur scientifique de grande
entreprise il y a aussi une attente de
leur part que
l'État soutiennent une recherche
publique qui ouvre les possibilités
parce que ça leur donne derrière aussi
la possibilité de d'aller piocher dans
ce qui dans ce qui va marcher ou pas
est-ce qu'ils auraient pas forcément
fait eux dans leur propre
laboratoire de recherche
ceci étant dit
l'ANR a mis en place un certain nombre
de dispositifs pour favoriser le travail
en commun entre les chercheurs d'une
part du secteur public et les
entreprises donc on a essentiellement
trois types de dispositifs pour faire
cela donc un qui s'appelle les projets
collaboratifs avec les entreprises comme
le nom l'indique
implique à la fois donc une entreprise
mais minimum une entreprise mais
également des établissements de
recherche publique pour travailler sur
un programme de recherche conjoint qui
va durer en général entre trois ou
quatre ans sur un programme précis donc
en réponse à un appel à projet de la nr
et notamment lorsqu'on a scindé l'axe
scientifique de l'appel à projet
générique de la NR qui portait sur
l'énergie en deux sous axes en deux axes
différents un qui porte plutôt sur la
recherche hameau destinée plutôt à
favoriser des recherches rupture le
deuxième par opposition lui des
positionner plutôt sur des TRL on va
dire intermédiaires donc plutôt nutrl 3
4 donc on se rapproche pratiquement du
prototype de laboratoire et cet axe là
très nettement il a suscité un afflux
beaucoup plus important que ce que l'on
avait avant de projet de type
collaboratif avec des entreprises on a
tout de suite vu l'effet de cette
programmation là avec cet axe là et un
intérêt des industriels pour s'intégrer
à ces projets portant sur des échelles
de terrain intermédiaires
outre les prce donc on a deux autres
instruments voilà nerf les lacoms les
Lacom donc laboratoire commun entre une
entreprise de type TPE et un laboratoire
public
qui sont plutôt des programmes de
recherche conjo donc plutôt de nouveau
accès sur des TRL intermédiaires donc un
travail bilatéral qui sont destinés à
favoriser le transfert de connaissances
et de technologie depuis le laboratoire
public vers l'industriel de type PME TPE
et notamment pour illustrer puisque le
sujet donc le sujet ici on a financé en
2017 un projet portant donc dans le
domaine de l'hydrogène
pour que porter par un laboratoire de
recherche de Montpellier spécialisés
dans les piles à combustibles et les
technologies d'hydrogène et la société
du live pour remplacer donc le gaz
naturel aujourd'hui utilisé dans les
brûleurs par exemple pour faire du
soudage ou des choses comme ça par de
l'hydrogène c'est un Lacom qui est dédié
à cette technologie là avec la société
Mulan illustrer les propos troisième
[Musique]
dispositif de soutien que la LMR a mis
en place pour favoriser ses relations
entre les entreprises et les
laboratoires publics ce sont les chair
industriels
et ces chers industriels en fait ou la
NR va financer à peu près la moitié de
l'aide dont a besoin de la chair et
l'industriel ou le groupe d'industriels
en question vont financer l'autre moitié
pour que l'élaboratoires impliqués dans
la chair le laboratoire impliqué dans la
chair travaille sur des sujets d'intérêt
pour ces industriels ou ces industriels
ou se content de l'industriel et on a
notamment financé dans ce cadre là une
chaire sur le transport d'hydrogène par
exemple récemment
voilà pour un peu illustrer sachant que
pour compléter cela
en général c'est vrai que la NR finance
plutôt des projets en appliquant que la
recherche publique entre très large
majorité on va dire
en revanche le ulcère c'est que dans le
domaine de l'énergie globalement et sur
les technologies qui nous intéressent
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de projets
qui arrivent à la fin à déposer des
brevets d'une part et dont on peut pour
une partie observer des suites qui
seront pas forcément financés par la NR
d'ailleurs qui peuvent être ensuite
financés par l'ADEME et je donnerai
l'exemple notamment
des projets que je mentionnais
rapidement en préambule sur les micros
wild vous avez dit que la NR des financé
un certain nombre de projets portant sur
les micro-alpes et très récemment on a
appris que la suite de ces projets là
avait
été financé par l'ADEME dans le cadre de
France 2030 donc à travers un gros
projet de démonstration
utilisant les résultats
de ces travaux préliminaires sur les
micros
merci Monsieur
le gris vous voulez
juste pour en ce qui concerne la
relation entre les entreprises et le
CNRS elles sont de longue date on a
enfin 2021 le CNRS a fait la création de
102 centièmes laboratoire commun entre
les entreprises le scénariste énormément
le
dispositif 6 pour le financement des
thèses qui est portée par la NRT et donc
les relations de du CNRS comme je le
disais avec les entreprises
remontent à bien très longtemps
évidemment toutes les disciplines du
génération pas concernées l'Institut de
chimie un de ceux qui a le plus de
relations avec l'entreprise il y a aussi
l'Institut de Physique la situation de
l'ingénieur l'Institut de l'informatique
et l'Institut des sciences biologiques
c'est ce sont les saints qui ont le plus
de relations avec des entreprises donc
beaucoup de
partenariats donc une entreprise un
laboratoire de recherche
mise en place ces dernières années d'un
outil de prématuration donc comment
aller pour transformer une recherche
d'un laboratoire d'intérêt pour
l'industriel comme on l'a porté vers une
spin-off quand c'est possible et ensuite
pour la maturation du CNRS et partenaire
d'un certain nombre et cet été sur tout
le territoire
si Daniel seulement
merci
merci pour vos présentations j'aurais
plusieurs questions la première concerne
l'hydrogène on sait que aujourd'hui avec
électrolyse on a un rendement alentours
de 30-35% au maximum donc on perd à peu
près 65 % de l'énergie de l'énergie
électrique qui a été impulsée pour faire
cette hydrogène sachant que si on part
une centrale nucléaire qui a déjà un
rendement de 30% en fait 35% on fait 30%
de 35% finit par avoir 10% de l'énergie
primaire est-ce qu'il y a un plafond
physique est-ce que on peut espérer que
la recherche améliore ce rendement ou
est-ce que il y a un moment on peut pas
aller plus loin que peut-être 40%, ce
que j'aimerais savoir concernant les
biocarburants je sais que vous vous êtes
sûr la partie recherche sur chimie et
physique par contre à la base il y a
quand même la biomasse bien entendu et
la problématique est c'est la
problématique de gisement puisque on
voit bien que par exemple pour pour
l'éthanol on parle de déchets mais ces
déchets ils ont déjà des exécutoirs
aujourd'hui on l'a vu quand on a fait la
mission information sur la méthanisation
la plus peu de betteraves elle est déjà
utilisée soit dans des materniseurs soit
pour des éleveurs donc est-ce qu'il y a
encore une marge de manœuvre sur des
produits sur tout ce qu'on appelait des
déchets qui s'appellent aujourd'hui des
coproduits et qui sont aujourd'hui et
bien
très recherché on va dire qui vont
l'aide de plus en plus alors est-ce
qu'on va pas avoir des filières est-ce
que vous travaillez également sur ces
différentes filières
est-ce que d'autres questions c'est que
par rapport
à un hectare de photovoltaïques
quelle est l'énergie produite sur une
année par un hectare de panneaux
photovoltaïques par rapport à l'énergie
qu'on va récupérer si on fait un hectare
de culture destiné à du un carburant un
biocarburant voilà j'aimerais bien
savoir un peu si vous avez des
comparatifs en ce sens là voilà ou sinon
vous avez dit parler de d'accv le bilan
carbone vous dites donc maintenant la
demande c'est 70% de moins qu'un
carburant fossile c'est bien ça
j'aimerais bien savoir le bilan carbone
des différents
biocarburants si vous les avez
bioéthanol que ce soit biogazole et
autres merci
alors du coup je laisserai à mon
collègue de Lifen toutes les questions
sur les biocarburants vous posez la
question de l'électrolyse et des limites
physiques donc les rendements que vous
citez c'est il faut bien regarder tous
les rendements pour la chaîne de valeur
et combien vous explorez la chaîne de
valeur parce que vous avez la production
d'hydrogène après vous avez son stockage
à distribution
son utilisation et donc là dessus ça va
évidemment varier en fonction des modes
d'utilisation
grosso modo la question vous posez
quelque part et est-ce bien raisonnable
de faire de l'hydrogène si le rendement
est inférieur et finalement dans votre
question ce qui manque c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on voudrait utiliser
l'hydrogène pourquoi on voudrait
utiliser un carburant durable pourquoi
est-ce qu'on voudrait utiliser à
biocarburant en fait il faut appeler la
vision comporte c'est d'appeler ces
vecteurs énergétiques en fonction du
service qu'on en attend c'est pour ça
que dans mon propos je vous ai indiqué
que sur un véhicule personnel léger et
bah oui une batterie qui aura un
rendement entre l'électricité
bac carbone qui va être utilisé et
l'énergie produite à bord à utiliser à
bord si elle est meilleure il faut
évidemment favoriser la batterie parce
que vous aurez un roman qui est meilleur
sur la partie gisement je vais surtout
laisser mon collègue de livret répondre
en particulier pour les biocarburants
c'était justement les points de
vigilance des vitres absolument tous les
conflits des âges parce que de la
biomasse des déchets forestiers
actuellement sont déjà valorisés dans
certaines filières et donc c'est bien là
mon point de vigilance aussi bien sur
l'énergie bas carbone que sur un
hydrogène que sur la ressource biomasse
il y a tous beaucoup de secteurs vont
appeler ces différentes ressources
renouvelables pour améliorer leur bilan
carbone il faut absolument anticiper et
éviter ces conflits d'usages l'Europe a
quelque part déjà répondu dans son feed
for fifty-five si vous prenez ce package
réglementaire pour le transport aérien
il a déjà été décidé qu'il y aurait une
dans la part des carburants durables qui
va être de 60% à l'horizon 2050 il y
aura une part qui ne devra pas être
d'origine biologique justement parce
qu'il est bien identifié qu'il faut
éviter un conflit d'usage
et que la ressource du masque ne pourra
pas répondre à tous les besoins à tous
les enjeux de cette filière
monsieur
je prends le relais sur la partie
biocarburant alors effectivement nous
donne domaine d'activité et
effectivement c'est plus la physique et
la chimie que la partie gisement comme
j'ai cité tout à l'heure il y a un
rapport de l'Impérial collège qui a été
fait et qui avait pour objectif de
recenser la disponibilité ou le
potentiel biomasse à l'échelle de
l'Europe et à démontrer en prenant en
compte les différents
usages qui avaient un potentiel biomasse
pour la partie biocarburant qui était en
France
quand je dis potentiel effectivement il
y a une structuration de la filière à
faire parce que aller chercher des
éclaircisse d'arbres aller chercher des
coupes d'élagage aujourd'hui et ben ce
n'est pas forcément fait dans tous les
secteurs dans toutes les régions et donc
c'est ces produits là qui va falloir
aller chercher plus tard pour pouvoir
apporter à la filière la ressource
nécessaire pour la production de
biocarburant donc il y a vraiment cet
aspect potentiel disponible et après
structurer la recherche allez structurer
la filière de la pour récupérer la
ressource là on parle de la ressource on
va dire conventionnelle qu'on faut
rester et agricole après la
réglementation européenne va nous ouvre
aussi l'opportunité d'utiliser d'autres
types de charges et là il y aura aussi
des enjeux de R&D de r ETI qui seront à
faire sur cette partie là l'utilisation
de bois B par exemple donc des résidus
de table et de construction du bâtiment
pour être une source d'utilisation qui
viendrait en complément de la ressource
forestière agricole des déchets ménagers
pour être aussi dans le futur une source
pour pouvoir approvisionner les unités
qui ont été en opération avec des
adaptations technologiques à faire avec
du développement à faire au niveau ri
mais ça pourrait être aussi une
éventualité pour augmenter le panel de
ressources
sur la partie 1 hectare photovoltaïque
par rapport à un hectare fou produit de
biocarburant et j'ai pas d'éléments
chiffrés à vous apporter je n'ai pas
fait l'étude spécifique sur le sur le
sujet donc je
commenterai pas plus sur cette partie là
sur la partie ACV les études ont montré
dans les projets qu'on était entre
plutôt aux alentours de 90% des
réductions des gaz de CO2 par rapport à
la référence fossile pour les procéder
de production d'éthanol avancé ou de
fuel synthétique avancé donc on est
quand même sur un niveau qui est
supérieur aux 70% de la réglementation
européenne et encore une fois ça demande
de l'énergie pour le faire
c'est soit cette séduction il à part la
part importante de du restaurant on va
dire des émissions c'est la partie
récupération de la biomasse et donc il y
a des enjeux sur cette sur cette filière
là
si je peux compléter sur les coûts où je
reviendrai plus tard sur le sujet
sur les coups donc on abordait donc
monsieur Cantat évoqué trois quatre
juste pour vous donner des ordres de
grandeur derrière sur les biocarbures
avancés en gros un coup de production
c'est 50% de l'investissement 25% la
ressource et 25 % les autres frais de
l'unité donc l'enjeu sur les subventions
à l'investissement sont pèse à un point
important sur la partie coût de
production finale et quand on dit
structurer la filière aussi pour la
ressource ça va être deux objectifs
d'aller récupérer la ressource pour
l'unité mais aussi d'aller la récupérer
à moindre coût et on voit que ce coup-là
pèse aussi 25% de du coût de production
donc voilà l'enjeu sur cette partie là
et sur la partie ifuel les chiffres ont
été cité trois quatre c'est pour la
partie biocarburant avancée des fioules
on se positionner un cran au dessus avec
un grand dépendance auprès d'électricité
comme on peut imaginer vu que ça va être
le vecteur énergétique pour apporter
l'hydrogène via la Via l'électrolyse
monsieur ben
oui vous voulez
oui
en vous entend bien parce que pour
rebondir peut-être sur les coups alors
sur l'hydrogène effectivement
aujourd'hui le coût de production par
électrolyse c'est estimé que 70% est
explicable par le prix d'électricité
donc voilà pour ça ça me donne un peu
alcool de grandeur je voulais quand même
mentionner
que bon je souscris totalement à ce qui
a été dit par Monsieur Cantat que
l'hydrogène par exemple
ne doit pas être utilisé pour tous les
types d'usages en termes de substitution
à ce que se faire avec le pétrole
aujourd'hui très clairement il sera
forcément réservé à un certain type
d'usage et c'est vrai aussi pour les
autres types de carburants qui ne peut
pas utiliser par exemple
l'électricité sous forme de stockés sous
forme de batterie je voulais aussi
mentionner qu'il y a d'autres limites à
la production
par exemple lorsqu'on veut produire de
l'hydrogène en utilisant des
électroviseurs thèmes alors c'est un peu
technique donc c'est des électroviseurs
qui fonctionnent à basse température
pour lesquelles justement le rendement
que vous avez cité et valable
aujourd'hui c'est cet homme de grandeur
de 40% ce qui est pas vrai sur d'autres
technologies par exemple la haute
température on peut monter beaucoup plus
haut même si c'est une technologie qui
est moins mature aujourd'hui mais sur
les électroviseurs de type thème une
autre limitation qui fait que de toute
façon
on ne pourra pas en avoir suffisamment
pour substituer totalement l'hydrogène
ou ressources pétrolières des ressources
aussi en général c'est que ces
préciseurs utilisent de l'iridium qui
est une ressource rare
voilà et qui va être une contrainte à
terme ce qui justifie aujourd'hui d'une
part que dans le cadre du PEPR sur
l'hydrogène décarbonée que soutient la
NR il y est en cours un projet qui vise
à réduire la teneur en iridium enfin
l'utilisation d'iridium dans ses
électrodiseurs de type PEM tout en
maintenant les rendements à l'état de
l'heure actuelle et d'autre part un
autre projet qui lui vise à substituer
totalement l'iridium par des catalyseurs
sans métaux nobles avec quand même des
perspectives commerciales intéressantes
en termes de rendement
voilà ce que je souhaitais ajouter sur
cette
juste un commentaire très général si on
veut augmenter les rendements donc il
faut de façon générale augmenter
température et abaisser l'école donc
utiliser des catalyseurs ça a été divisé
par mes collègues donc il y a des
recherches fondamentales après
des fois faut être conscient que
l'énergie disponible et largement
sous-utilisée je vais vous donner un
exemple que je veux pas polémique dans
l'esprit nucléaire on utilise
aujourd'hui quelques pourcents de
l'uranium si on ferme le cycle on
pourrait utiliser davantage
merci Pierre qui perce oui merci
monsieur le Président
j'ai une question tout à fait simple à
laquelle chacun nous intervenants va
pouvoir répondre facilement
vous avez tous évoqué d'ailleurs les
coûts élevés de la recherche du
développement du déploiement par rapport
et la compétitivité par rapport aux
énergies actuelles aux énergies fossiles
et autres
ma question est simple est-ce que vous
avez fait une étude du coût de notre
dépendance énergétique
énergie par énergie
pour comparer non pas seulement toujours
par rapport aux énergies actuelles mais
par rapport à ce que nous coûte les
énergies et notre fragilité
énergétique voilà
si pour la simple question
qui répond
monsieur
alors ma réponse au premier ordre est
très simple le CE est un opérateur de
recherche et n'a pas ces éléments
macroscopiques pour répondre maintenant
au deuxième ordre à titre personnel
il faut bien qu'on ait conscience quand
même que 85% d'énergie mondiale à
l'heure actuelle c'est de l'énergie
chimique qu'on extrait du sous-sol qu'on
brûle pour récupérer l'électricité et
chaleur autrement dit on n'a pas quitté
la du feu
voilà et donc le grand paradigme qu'on
essaye de renverser aujourd'hui de
changer d'amorcer c'est finalement de
produire de l'électricité bas carbone et
d'être capable de retransformer cet
électricité sous une forme d'énergie
chimique pourquoi parce que ça a
énormément de sens d'utiliser de la
biomasse ou du pétrole parce que
l'énergie chimique elle est stockée elle
est facile à stocker à garder pendant
des longues périodes elle est
extrêmement dense en énergie elle est
facile d'utilisation et elle abondante
et donc on a besoin de re basculer
l'énergie électrique mais aussi
l'énergie solaire on l'a mentionné un
petit peu sur les carburant solaire on a
encore des niveaux de maturité encore
plus bas de les transformer energie
solaire et énergie électrique sous cette
forme d'énergie chimique et ce
changement de paradoxe de paradigme il
est massif parce que vous voyez bien
qu'on n'a pas quitté l'âge du feu depuis
la préhistoire de façon macroscopique et
du coup c'est ça qui légitime quelque
part des coups de déploiement
important
qui sont non non qui sont pas du tout
comparables après vous avez une autre
question dans votre question qui est les
aspects d'externalité liés à notre
système énergétique la dépendance par
exemple aux énergies fossiles qui
viennent toutes de l'extérieur du
territoire national enfin la plupart
viennent du l'extérieur du territoire
national ce sont des éléments qui
généralement de par notre construction
économique ne sont pas pris correctement
compte et complètement en compte donc
c'est évidemment quelque chose qu'il
faut réinternaliser et faire des
biocarburants si on a la ressource
biomasse faire de l'hydrogène si on a la
ressource on électricité bas carbone
qu'elle soit d'origine nucléaire ou
d'origine renouvelable à la limite peu
importe faire des ifuel à partir de
nucléaires et d'énergie renouvelable ça
oui si ça peut nous amener plus
d'indépendance et de souveraineté ça
doit faire partie de l'équation mais
c'est pour ça que j'insistais sur cette
question découle les coups sont plus
importants parce qu'on les compare à des
coûts qui sont complètement biaisés
aujourd'hui qui sont les coûts du
fossile sur lesquels on intègre pas la
dépendance vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
sur lesquels on intègre pas encore
le prix environnemental et les pénalités
sur la générations futures donc en fait
c'est quoi ils sont complètement biaisés
il faut bien définir quel est le service
qu'on veut rendre global
[Musique]
vous vous voulez réagir vous voulez
peut-être effectivement alors pour me
défoncer en partie parce que moi aussi
je n'ai pas creusé la question donc la
réponse à la question qui a été posée
sur les approches on va dire
macroéconomique en revanche je voulais
quand même signaler que de mémoire la NR
a financé des projets portant sur ces
questions là dont je suis tout à fait
incapable aujourd'hui de vous restituer
des conclusions mais qui s'intéressait
effectivement à ses effets d'ordre
macroéconomique
de la dépendance énergétique
ça existe et qu'il y a eu des travaux de
chercheurs sur ces questions là
monsieur le gris je dirais pas mieux une
question de coups moi ce que et pour
revenir un petit peu sur les relations
avec manuscrit ce que je peux dire c'est
tous ces sujets là passionne vraiment la
communauté nos laboratoires sont
extrêmement sous tension aujourd'hui
très sollicité par l'ensemble des
sociétés ou des entreprises qui ont un
lien avec les domaines dont on parle
aujourd'hui donc faut être conscient
qu'il y a un changement en cours
important
aussi bien de la part de l'industrie que
la part de la recherche
sur la porte oui rapidement vous avez
assez peu parlé de enfin de
l'interaction avec le niveau européen
dans les programmes de recherche
dans la définition de la maturité des
différents process et filières etc bon
premier élément et deuxièmement comment
s'est organisé au niveau info européen
et français d'ailleurs pour avoir des
points de rendez-vous avec les pouvoirs
publics sur sur tout ça parce qu'après
vous vous faisiez à l'usure tout à
l'heure la question c'est aussi en terme
de souveraineté comment on est capable
de faire les choix au bon moment de
bâtir les filières de produire vous
évoquez tout à l'heure l'aviation bon il
y a des objectifs qui sont très clairs
mais on voit bien quand même
qu'aujourd'hui les compagnies commencent
à
signer des contrats qui sont pas
forcément en France quoi bon du coup
voilà quels sont les les clauses de
rendez-vous et est-ce que il y a comme
ça des points où on regarde réellement
où on en est et à quel moment on va
devoir faire des choix clairs
vous commencez monsieur Quentin
alors il y a deux éléments votre
question si j'ai bien compris
l'interaction avec le niveau européen
est quand même l'interaction entre le
tissu industriel et la commande publique
quelque part
alors au niveau européen
il y a deux niveaux de structuration qui
ont des maturités différentes je disais
sur l'hydrogène vous avez déjà
des publics partner ship qui sont en
place deux
ipcu donc il y a quand même une
structuration à l'échelle européenne qui
existe pour justement
faciliter les liens entre la recherche
publique et le tissu industriel
il n'y a pas d'équivalent à ce jour sur
les biocarbures et encore moins sur les
fioules donc il y a quelque chose à
construire néanmoins il y a des
associations
de d'organismes de recherche avec des
industriels par exemple sur la
valorisation du CO2 pour aller faire des
carburants qui s'appelle si YouTube
value up qui a justement é positionné
sur ce secteur là d'essayer de mettre du
lien dans la communauté à travers le
tissu que ça aille de la du tissu de la
recherche académique la recherche
technologique et des industriels et même
des collectivités et du coup ce sont des
associations qui sont particulièrement
intéressantes pour pouvoir faire émerger
une maturité une communauté qui soit
structurée et porter un message au
niveau européen
sur la partie le lien avec la commande
publique
est un organisme de recherche donc c'est
pas notre mission de faire ça mais à ma
connaissance les stratégies
d'accélération finalement participent à
cette structuration ou préfiguration des
filières puisqu'on a une stratégie
d'accélération autour de l'hydrogène ba
carbone une autre stratégie
d'accélération autour de la
décarbonation industrie et enfin une
autre sur les biocarburants les
bioproduits et les carburants durables
donc il y a une préfiguration ici et les
communautés stratégiques de filière en
particulier celui sur NSE sur un nouveau
système énergétique
en particulier cette mission aussi
je crois que pour la partie Union
européenne enfin j'abonde dans le sens
de
l'ipcei sur la partie sur cette partie
là qui a pas été qui a pas été dédié sur
la partie biocarburant et qui peut être
une voie pour favoriser le déploiement
des filières il y avait d'autres
programmes d'aide qui était fait mais
qui était un peu beaucoup plus large
dans les thématiques et donc le choix
des projets était pas toujours évident
non plus donc ça ça fait partie des
sujets il y a pas mal d'organisations
qui sont présentes au niveau de
Bruxelles qui ont sur lequel on a des
retours aussi pour pouvoir justement
émettre des nouvelles idées donner des
tendances sur les sur les caps
d'incorporation de biocarburant avancé
dans le pool dans les poules
énergétiques et ça c'est l'objet des
directives européennes qui vont découler
aussi dans ce cadre là donc là dessus il
y a pas mal de sujets la ressource aussi
fait partie des des liens qu'on peut
avoir que la partie Union européenne
sur le deuxième point j'ai pas forcément
j'ai pas de commentaire particulier
monsieur ben
oui je peux apporter quelques réponses
sur le premier point du côté Amr donc
côté Hainer en fait on est impliqué dans
des partenariats puisque c'est
aujourd'hui que le slack ça s'appelle
dans le cadre du programme Horizon
Europe donc
des partenariats qui sont au niveau
européen entre agence de financement
donc on a mentionné des partenariats
donc ce qui a été fait par Monsieur
compta concernant l'hydrogène donc ça
c'est un partenariat de longue date qui
est entièrement financé par l'Europe et
à côté de ça il existait il existe
encore aujourd'hui donc des partenariats
impliquant des agences de type ANR donc
des agences nationales qui mettent en
commun leur moyen et définissent
ensemble des objectifs pour financer des
projets de recherche transnationaux et
notamment la NR est impliquée dans un
partenariat qui porte sur un certain
nombre de questions de l'énergie qui se
veut complémenter du partenariat sur
l'hydrogène mais également d'autres
partenariats dédiés plus spécifiquement
aux différents modes de transport par
exemple mais qui va traiter de la
question des biocarbures qui elles par
exemple font très peu l'objet de
d'autres partenariats mais également de
la valorisation du CO2 et je souligne
d'ailleurs que ce nouveau partenariat
européen sur l'énergie lancé dans le
cadre d'horizon Europe s'appuie sur un
ancien dispositif qui existait
précédemment qui s'appelait celui des
éradettes
il y avait les mêmes objectifs peut-être
à des échelles moins ambitieuses mais
dont l'un auxquels avait participé à la
fois la NR mais également la courbe qui
portait donc sur tout ce qui était le
captage valorisation
usage de stockage du CO2 donc ce qu'on
appelle
dans lesquels en fait on a été impliqué
il a permis de financer quelques projets
avec des partenaires français notamment
un projet qui s'appelle next CCUS qui
vise à produire massivement du méthanol
à partir de CO2 issus de captage et
d'énergie solaire
je voulais quand même aussi mentionné
que dans le cadre du site Variat on
discuteront avec les autres agences
impliquées et donc les autres pays on
s'aperçoit que les stratégies du point
de vue énergétique peuvent être assez
différentes je donnerais l'exemple de
l'hydrogène on a parlé nous ici surtout
de l'hydrogène bas carbone décarbonée
principalement l'hydrogène obtenu par
électrolyse en fait électrolyse de l'eau
on s'aperçoit on discutant avec les
autres pays que c'est pas toujours la
stratégie qui est suivie notamment les
pays qui ont accès naturellement aux gaz
naturel par exemple Norvège mais
peut-être d'autres pays du nord de
l'Europe elle envisage aussi de produire
de l'hydrogène va carbone à partir de
naturel on le couplant par exemple au
captage du CO2
voilà pour ma contribution sur ce point
merci Monsieur legrine juste sur les
programmes européens donc il y a un
certain nombre de programmes européens
qui ont financé des projets autour des
batteries et qui continuent à financer
par exemple il y a eu sur les
biographies par le passé donc le CNRS
inscrit dans ses recherches
collaboratives au niveau européen donc
au delà de ce qu'on appelle les ERC qui
financent des projets individuels il
existe des projets collaboratifs
bien merci moi j'ai trois questions j'ai
bien je suis allé noté qu'il fallait une
réglementation stable merci Martine
que la construction de mix et dernier
génétique nécessitait de ne pas
forcément mettre les différentes
filières en concurrence et puis vous
avez parlé d'investissement donc pas
première question c'est sur le volet
financier est-ce que vous considérez
aujourd'hui que les investisseurs qu'ils
soient public ou privés
accompagnent suffisamment le passage de
la recherche à la transformation
industrielle et deuxième question c'est
considérez-vous que la recherche
développement que nous menons en France
permet à notre pays d'être bien placé au
sein de l'Union européenne et enfin
quel regard portez-vous sur la stratégie
de recherche et industrielle des
États-Unis
[Musique]
vous commencez du coup je commence merci
beaucoup alors vous aurez bien compris
ma position
d'expert c'est à dire que je vous dis
quand je ne sais pas je vous dire
quand il faut raffiner en l'occurrence
sur ces différentes questions encore une
fois le CE1 opérateur de recherche sur
on n'a pas du tout les chiffres
quantitatifs qui permettraient d'avoir
une vision consolidée sur ces différents
points donc j'ai pas beaucoup d'éléments
à vous fournir après mon sentiment à
titre personnel en tant qu'expert c'est
que
j'ai pas d'avis sur les investissements
et j'aurais du mal à les comparer j'ai
pas de j'ai pas de chiffres sur la R&D
est-ce que nous sommes bien placés enfin
la France était bien placée dans l'Union
européenne et après comparativement aux
États-Unis
où je pense que oui la France est bien
placé au niveau de l'Union européenne on
a un tissu académique qui est très très
dynamique et on a aussi on prend par
exemple les plans hydrogène qui ont été
décidés la France a un plan hydrogène
avec des financements qui sont
légèrement inférieurs à l'Allemagne mais
du même ordre de grandeur donc on peut
pas dire que il y ait qu'on est à rougir
ou ou à se plaindre de ce point de vue
là on est plutôt bien passé dans les R&D
par rapport aux États-Unis j'ai pas de
j'ai pas d'a à proprement parler sur la
question ce qu'on pourra noter c'est
quand même quand on voit le
infection Act qui qui prévoit des
investissements évidemment des soutiens
à l'investissement donc jouer sur les
CAPEX mais aussi sur les Opex c'était un
petit peu mon message en propos
liminaire c'est une composante qui nous
manque énormément au niveau européen ce
soutien sur les oplex et donc il faut
prendre en compte pour créer des parts
de marché pour avoir des prix de rachat
qui permettent d'amorcer la filière donc
toujours avec une approche de pas
forcément les ancrés dans une grande
pérennité mais au moins avoir une
dynamique d'amorcer les filières
merci Monsieur Hérault ce qu'on peut
remarquer sur la première question par
rapport aux investissement quand on
discute sur les projets et quand on voit
les monteurs les projets qui sont
aujourd'hui
tel budget c'est plutôt des monteurs de
projet plutôt que des grands groupes
industriels qui sont porteurs des
projets sur les biocarburants avancés et
donc ça c'est aussi un peu nouveau sur
le panorama de l'énergie peut-être que
le relais sera pris plus tard mais sur
les phases qui sont les premières phases
d'un développement de projets industriel
c'est 5 ans avant d'arriver sur une
unité de construction c'est des monteurs
de projets qui prennent les premiers
risques donc ça c'est quand même assez
nouveau je pense pour la deuxième
question que la France est plutôt bien
passée par rapport à l'Europe et on a eu
du soutien ce qui a été montré à travers
les subventions et l'aide de l'ADEME
pour les deux projets que j'ai cités sur
le futur les beautiful ça contribue à ça
on a à savoir faire technique sur la
partie énergie qui est important et
qu'on s'est valorisé é donc continuons
sur cette sur cette voie là
et la stratégie du S alors stratégie du
S sur la partie recherche j'ai pas trop
je sais pas trop comment ça s'organise
par contre en terme de produits ils sont
pas du tout sur le même type de
biocarburant que nous aussi donc ça ça
fait une vraie différence sur la partie
marché il considère aujourd'hui que la
1g est une solution pour eux alors qu'en
Europe on est quand même sur des
biocarbures avancés et ça ça fait une
vraie différence en terme de de
stratégie d'industrialisation
sur la première question je vais être un
peu comme Monsieur Cantat ça échappe au
domaine de compétences de la NR et à mon
domaine du compétence personnelle en
revanche sur les deuxièmes les 3e
question je peux apporter quelques
éléments de réponse alors sur la
deuxième question sur la position en
Europe elle est plutôt bonne de mon
point de vue à la fois par les
financements qu'on apporte au niveau
national aujourd'hui parce que en fait
il faut bien comprendre que depuis l'an
passé pratiquement en fait
essentiellement et la mise en place des
premiers PPE ça suscite que et des
stratégies nationales plus globalement
donc un soutien qui est massif et on
espère pas ponctuel parce que on espère
que ça va quand même durer un petit peu
au-delà de l'investissement initial donc
à la R&D je pense que ça contribue
beaucoup l'autre élément que je voulais
apporter sur cette question là c'est la
place des
chercheurs français dans les dispositifs
européens soutenus directement par
l'Union européenne notamment en a
mentionné le partenariat public privé
sur l'hydrogène j'avais regardé il y a
deux ans qu'elle avait été un peu le la
réussite des organismes publics de
recherche français
dans ce partenariat public privé je
reprends mes notes ici en fait je suis
aperçu que sur la période
2008-2017 que j'avais regardé que les
organismes de recherche publique
français sont des bénéficiaires
importantes ces appels à projets
européens
ils sont partenaires de 57% des projets
c'est pas tout à fait au même niveau que
les Allemands mais pas très loin et
c'est bien au-dessus
bien au dessus des du Royaume-Uni par
exemple qui est troisième avec seulement
36 projets donc en fait on est plutôt
deuxième pas très loin de l'Allemagne en
tout cas sur les technologies
d'hydrogène globalement en termes de
bénéficier de la R&D financer
directement par l'Europe dernier élément
sur ce point-là on est aussi porteur
d'une initiative qui aujourd'hui n'a pas
pu trouver de financement européen en
dehors d'une CSA alors je suis du cycle
dans cette cible européen coordination
insupportaction qui vise à développer
les recherches dans le domaine des
carburants solaires principalement et
midi carburant qui s'appelle synergie
c'est le CEA qui en est un des grands
promoteurs en Europe
et donc on a un rôle vraiment de leader
sur cet aspect là pour répondre à la
troisième question sur comment les
États-Unis sont organisés pour soutenir
leur R&D et le transfert industrie alors
j'avais regardé il y a quelques années
quelque chose de très intéressant donc
qui en fait passe essentiellement par
les soutiens apportés au niveau d'une
agence qui s'appelle le doivement de
penalgies donc aux États-Unis qui
soutient en fait la R&D à travers trois
grands dispositifs
le premier dispositif vise à soutenir
une recherche de base fondamentale
qui comme je l'ai mentionné au début et
toujours nécessaire pour faire germer
les idées nouvelles et voir ce qui peut
déboucher donc il soutiennent la
recherche un peu tout azimut dans
différents domaines scientifiques la
notions etc sur des matériaux
le deuxième dispositif que j'ai trouvé
particulièrement intéressant c'est un
dispositif qui est inspiré de ce que
faisait
les armées aux États-Unis donc la Tarpa
principalement